is there a magic number or an ideal
percentage this was a viewer question
for like average view duration of a
short for it to go viral or what
ingredients would make a short go viral
I think like part of it
um like there's never a set numbers the
same thing on long form video like as a
long form video when it hits your core
audience the retention might be really
high because you know they love you and
they want they're more likely to watch a
high percentage of your video but then
as it starts going viral and it starts
being served to bigger and bigger
audiences those audiences are less and
less well-matched just because the
volume is getting so great but it's such
a huge amount the percentage of people
watching like three percent of a million
is so much bigger than 20 of a thousand
that you're still racking up views and
when you look at it it's like oh like my
CTR is way down my retention is way down
but my views are way up and that's the
sort of pressure that going viral does
so I think some people look at it and
say like what's the retention rate for
like a short to go viral it's the same
sort of pressure as more more people see
it there's more and more people who will
like watch it yes but also swipe away so
you'll see downward pressure on that
rate so I think like you have to get a
sense of how your shorts typically
perform and then measure your new shorts
against that sort of number like when I
get this many Impressions what's my
usual retention when I get this many
Impressions when I have like a viral
short and outliers are nice because
everyone loves that flat retention line
but doesn't teach you very much where
when you have like an underperforming
video or an over performing video and
you can see oh they dropped off here or
are here all these spikes I guess that
joke didn't land the way I intended it
to land that's when you can start to get
that kind of gnarly data out of it so I
think like figure out what's a good
retention for your shorts with the
average amount of views you get and then
always try to improve that like see
where it's dropping off and like think
like is there a b plot or a joke or a
beat or like a reset I can do that will
get that to continue and compete against
you more than you compete against
YouTube two things number one I've had
too much coffee today number two if you
have not seen our free master class yet
you're gonna love it if you're serious
about growing your YouTube channel just
go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class